Welcome to the presentation on
finding the equation of a line.
Let's get started.
Say I had two points.
Let's say I have the point 1
comma 2, and I have the point 3
comma 4, and I want to figure
out the equation of the
line through these points.
So let's at least figure out
what that line looks like.
So 1 comma 2 is here,
and 2, 3; 3, 4.
3 comma 4 is here, and if
I want to draw a line
through them, it'll look
something like that.
So what we want to do is figure
out the equation of this line.
Well, we know the form of an
equation of a line is y equals
mx plus b, where m is the
slope, and that tells you how
steep the line is, and
b is the y-intercept.
And I don't know why
people chose m and b.
We'll have to do some
research on that.
b is the y-intercept and the
y-intercept is just where does
it intersect the y-axis.
And this problem, you could
actually look at it and
figure it out, but let's
do it mathematically.
So the equation for the slope
m: it's rise over run.
Another way to view that is
for any amount that you
run along the x-axis,
how much do you rise?
Well, let's do
that numerically.
Rise is the same thing as
change over y, and run is the
same thing as change over x.
Delta, this triangle, means
change, change in y.
Well, change in y, let's
take the starting
point to be 3 comma 4.
Let's say we're going from
3 comma 4 to 2 comma 1.
The change in y is 4 minus 2.
We just took this 4 minus
this 2 over 3 minus 1.
My phone was ringing.
And that's just this
3 minus this 1.
So if we just solve for it,
we get 4 minus 2 is 2, and 3
minus 1 is also 2, so we get
the slope is equal to 1.
And that makes sense because
when we move over 1 in x,
we go up exactly 1 in y.
When we move to the left 1 in
x, we move down exactly 1 in y.
So now we know the equation is
y equals 1x plus b because
we solved the m equals 1.
And this is, of course,
the same thing as
y equals x plus b.
Now, all we have left
to do is solve for b.
Well, how do we do that because
we have three variables here.
Well, we could actually
substitute one of these pairs
of points in for y and x, and
that makes sense, because
these points have to
satisfy this equation.
So let's take this first
pair. y is equal to 2.
2 is equal to x,
which is 1 plus b.
It's a pretty easy
equation to solve.
We get b equals 1, so that
tells us that the equation of
this line is y equals x plus 1.
That's a pretty straightforward
equation, and it makes sense.
The y-intercept is 1, which
is exactly here, 0 comma
1, and the slope is 1, and
that's pretty obvious.
For every amount that we move
to the right, we move the same
amount up, so the slope is 1.
Let's do another problem.
Let's say I wanted to find the
equation of the line between
the points negative 3 comma
5 and 2 comma negative 6.
Well, we do the same thing.
m is equal to change in
y over change in x.
So let's take this as
the starting point.
So say negative 6 minus 5.
So we just took negative
6 minus 5 over 2
minus negative 3.
You've got to be real careful
to get the signs right.
So it's 2 minus negative 3.
Negative 6 minus 5 is minus 11,
and 2 minus negative 3, well,
that's the same thing as two
plus plus 3, so that's 5.
So we have the slope is
equal to negative 11/5.
And notice that if on the
numerator we use negative 6 as
the starting point, that in the
denominator, we have to use
2 as the starting point.
We could have done it
the other way around.
We could have said 5 minus
negative 6 over negative 3
minus 2, in which case we would
have gotten-- this would have
been 11 over negative 5.
So as long as you-- if you use
the negative 6 first, then you
have to use the 2 first, or if
you use the 5 first, then
you have to use the
negative 3 first.
I hope I'm not completely
confusing you guys.
Well, anyway, we know the slope
is negative 11/5, so the
equation of this line so far is
y equals minus 11/5x plus b.
Now we can take one of these
pairs on the top and substitute
back and solve for b.
Let's take the first pair.
So 5 is y.
So we say 5 equals negative
3, so it's negative 11/5
times negative 3, right?
I just put the x
in for x plus b.
So just simplifying that, I get
5 is equal to 33/5 plus b, or b
is equal to 5 minus 33/5, and
this equals 25 minus 33/5.
25 minus 33 is minus 8/5.
So the equation of this line,
and this one wasn't as clean as
the other one, obviously, is--
let me do it in another color
for emphasis-- y equals
minus 11/5x minus 8/5.
Hopefully, those two examples
will give you enough of an idea
to do the figuring out the
equation of a line problems.
And if you have problems with
this, you might just want to
try just the slope of the line
problems or the y-intercept
problems separately.
I hope you have fun.
Bye.